No,
but you need more orange.
Welcome everybody
to the h three podcasts experience.
So great to have you with us.
Great.
Does see that.
If you look really beautiful today with
your Auntie and great idea,
I switched like three buildings until I
decided on the orange.
The orange looks great and I want to
thank our sponsors today.
Stitch fix or ring seatgeek end quid
today.
We've got a whole slew of juicy topics
to get to,
including Greg Paul,
the father of Jake and Logan.
Paul has not only made a tape and what
she is having a,
how do I say this without getting in
trouble with youtube where a,
he's uh,
his Janet Ohs is going into a female
genitals.
People have speculated that this tape,
that it records his gentleman was going
into another person's gender roles.
Sex tape.
You could say sex tape.
Yeah.
It's like save time.
Right?
That's the,
I don't know.
Um,
he's had,
people are speculating.
That's an underage girl.
There's no evidence of that at all.
Why is it still called a tape?
It's not really a tape.
Is it?
Hmm.
We need to update that sex footage.
Vid tape sounds a little more like
hidden away though.
It's like,
oh,
I got that tape in my pocket.
But really it's just on your phone.
Yeah.
So it's not that fun anymore,
but sex tape,
it still is.
Sec State be up a post.
Malone has apparently been cursed.
I love this story.
It's great.
And of course the Hilarious,
hilarious antics of reporters from the
recent hurricane.
Um,
there's a new trend and not really a new
trend.
They've been doing it for ages where
they just stand and hurricanes and it's
hilarious.
And I've put together a whole thing.
So these are this,
this,
and so much more.
Welcome everybody to the age three buck
gas beyond the experience.
Fully enlightened.
I'm your host Ethan client with the
beautiful,
talented,
lovely,
incredible levine.
He look like.
Thank you.
Love of my life.
Beautiful.
Whoa.
So good that well
enough about Ila.
Let's get to the one person in the world
who turns me on even more.
Greg Paul now.
Okay.
So let's start from the top because this
is a whole story that's kind of develop.
So I want to explain to you guys from
the top what happened.
Okay.
Now,
first of all,
I think the first thing that happened in
Dan,
correct me if I'm wrong on anything,
but I think I've got my facts straight,
is that Logan Paul's channel was hacked.
Hmm.
And the attacker,
uh,
uploaded a basically a fake iphone
giveaway,
which is honestly not that much of a
departure from his usual content.
So I'm surprised anyone even noticed
because they took it down really fast.
Click the link in the description to
claim your free iphone x giving away
1500.
I iphones.
Apparently people were clicking this
link and just getting like straight up
key loggers and viruses,
which is great.
You know,
all the best stuff on the Internet has
to offer.
So that got taken down pretty quickly.
And um,
on Sunday the hackers released jake
pauls calendar via their twitter pages
since been banned.
It included the address and contact info
for many celebrities,
including Justin Bieber.
Yikes.
And what was thought?
This is a great twist thought to be
Ethan me,
of course.
That's me.
Um,
when Jake Paul was on our podcast,
he saved a dance number because he had a
pre show call with Dan and he saved it
as h three h three.
So Dan's phone number was leaked over a
blowing up with a phone call.
That was fun.
Tell me about that then.
Um,
it was a Sunday afternoon,
um,
was just chilling at home and all of a
sudden get a call from an unknown
number.
Oh,
that's weird.
You answered it.
No,
I ignored it.
What kind of maniac answers don't know
numbers in 2018.
Yeah,
absolutely.
But as soon as it ended,
uh,
another one and then another one,
another one,
and pretty quickly I was like,
okay,
something,
something happened and this is,
this is not normal.
And uh,
yeah,
just tracked it down to the old Jakey
poop.
Did you not answer one of the calls?
No.
And I didn't get any texts or anything.
Yeah.
Texts.
Well again,
because they thought it was you.
So it was just all kinds of people
saying what's up Ethan?
And like all kinds of messages for you.
So anything interesting to know?
No.
Really nothing interesting at all,
which I mean these people,
it's like you get ahold of a number of a
famous person,
they have no idea what to say.
You're just calling the call.
I'll say when I'm on my phone number got
leaked previously when we got hacked
dealer and they posted our phone number
on twitter and we were,
we were pro,
I swear to God we're getting like a
hundred calls a minute.
Fun Ways.
Actually it,
I can't,
I couldn't access my phone cause there
was just incoming calls nonstop.
You couldn't like swipe it open.
I couldn't even do anything.
But I was getting tons of text messages
and I don't think I actually ever told
you this,
but somebody sent me,
I don't know why I even open text
message cause I was generally not.
But one of them was a dick pic and I
have to tell you,
I did feel violated.
And in that moment I had a,
I had a moment of like empathy and
sympathy for all the females out there
getting unsolicited dick pics because it
felt,
it felt very,
I felt very violated that I saw this
man.
He was a fat man with the tiny small
penis.
It looked almost like my own,
if I'm being honest,
a tiny little penis.
The pubes were much longer than the
penis itself and I was like,
whoa.
Is that a picture I took?
No,
it was someone sending me their own.
So,
um,
and that you would think it was his
fixture and not something off the
Internet?
No,
it was definitely,
dude just snapped his junk and send it
to me.
Yeah.
So there's a fat chubby little penis.
I was me to it.
I've been trying to tell you that for a
long time.
I'm trying to take back.
Me Too,
for us,
for me meat anyway,
apparently me third,
apparently the hacker,
this,
this kind of perplexes me,
this hacker gotten to Jake Logan and
their father's account,
all three.
Like,
I mean these guys are big shots.
They had run big companies.
How first of all,
is there security,
not tighter run third of all,
how do you get into all three of them at
the same time?
What I was wondering is are they still
all on the same family plan at Verizon
or some shit?
You know what I mean?
Like how do you explain that they got
all three of their account?
Fascinating stuff.
Well,
regardless of how it happened,
um,
it could only happen to these geniuses.
Um,
apparently just so in Jake's dms,
there was all kinds of stuff of him
flirting with girls.
I don't know,
they teased all kinds of stuff,
but they didn't show anything.
So I don't know.
But definitely the most fucked up thing
to come out of it by far was the Greg
Paul sex tape.
Greg Paul being the father.
Um,
this guy's a piece of work,
man.
Greg Paul's the guy who has notoriously
made out with little girls and one of
Jake's videos kiss.
I mean there might have been and he
seems he wears a,
he's,
he's 40.
How old is he,
Danny?
He's like 40,
50,
54.
Yeah,
I think that's right.
I mean here,
here's all you need to know about the
guy.
He's a 54 year old man with a puka shell
necklace and a goatee.
I mean that's a,
it says all you need.
Hit me with some of those soundbites,
which is that [inaudible]
gp coming at Ya GP.
He's coming at Ya two talks.
He like lowers his voice,
talks like a 19 year old irritation of
his sons.
Yeah.
Yo.
Hey Yo,
is jp coming at Cha?
Ooh,
what's going on?
He's auditioning for the new blues clues
open.
Uh,
anyway,
so,
so there was a sex tape,
but there's no faces.
There's some voices,
obviously the girl herself.
There's no way of knowing her age or
identity,
which is good for her.
Thank God for that.
I mean it's so graphic you guys.
I've watched a lot of porn in my day.
A lot of porn.
I mean emphasize a lot of foreign in my
day.
This is one of the most things I've ever
seen in my life.
I mean,
it is horrible.
Mba was horrifying,
truly horrific.
Let me play you a little soundbite.
The lovely thing was that it was just on
twitter and like I just saw people
talking about it going up the thread of
a conversation.
It's just they're on twitter and yeah,
that's how I saw it first till.
But I saw what I saw was like him,
like fingering her.
But then I do my research.
I watched the whole thing on one of
these,
uh,
you know,
websites and it is old graphic brothers.
The one scene where he's slapping her
with his Dick,
I'm going to use,
I'm going to use a PC words here because
we are family friendly show.
He uses his a carrot.
He,
he puts his care and her soil.
But what happens is he's slapping her,
slapping her peace with this carrot and
she starts to water his carrot.
He,
she pees on his dick.
I swear to God,
And this is the sound that it makes this
sound from the video.
She pees on his dick.
I swear to God.
So he's slapping her and she's paying on
his deck.
Do you think,
Eh,
Fmr people would love this sound.
[inaudible] Greg Faull sex dig a smrs
interested.
Let me try to experience stuff that
space tomorrow.
I'm definitely getting the tone alone.
I'm still in a tingle and my forehead.
Um,
so this video is so graphic.
but again,
there's no,
there's nothing identifying the man or,
or the female.
So my first thought was that,
okay,
it could be anyone.
Let's look,
first of all,
I want to see is this actually Greg
Paul?
Not that I'm not willing to believe it.
I mean I'm very willing to believe it,
but I just want to know what's my hunch.
So here we've got some evidence here.
Um,
let me see here.
he ready to come again.
Definitely sounds like a hit me with the
Hemi with that Zach could be,
but I will.
Here we do a little CSI photo matching
and this is fairly conclusive in my
opinion.
Um,
here it's hard to tell.
Okay.
But like,
here's a,
from his instagram has dog sleeping on
his bed.
Now what we're paying our attention to
is this floral kind of pattern here in
the woodwork.
And you can tell.
I know it's,
I know this doesn't look that good.
Okay.
Not,
but I'm telling you,
I've watched the videos,
there's better screenshots,
but it definitely,
it matches it's the same ad board and
when it's in motion in the video,
a lot more evidence that it's the same
thing.
It's definitely the same.
So what do you think is happening?
But um,
I thought I had more evidence than that.
Okay.
Well let's leave the evidence I've got.
It's okay.
Let me say this.
It's definitely the same headboard
and European and my humble alleged
opinion.
It's not even an opinion.
It's an alleged that your opinion sir,
allegedly,
um,
under age though.
I mean,
who could ever say that that's
dangerous?
Yeah.
I don't,
I don't want to put out the guys having
sex with underage girls.
I will believe him.
He was having what I would it be a
stretch of my imagination to think that
greg was having sex on average girls?
No,
absolutely not because of him kissing.
Absolutely not.
Um,
but what,
what she had happened.
Cause it's,
if,
what if he was what it's from some
hackers.
Well.
Yeah,
the first thought I had was like,
that's not,
you can't really use that as evidence in
court because it's illegally obtained.
Yeah.
Well regardless,
there's no evidence to disclose under
age at all.
So,
um,
I don't want to insinuate that now.
Basically though,
Greg has acknowledged that the hack has
happened in this instagram video in
which I will play for you all here
today.
Just some little,
some they'll tell you over as I opened
this,
by the way,
Greg is a high level instagram user.
He starts the video with,
he got a paper bag from like Ralph's
supermarket and he just sharpied a
message so that this would be the
thumbnail.
It's very creative.
I am calling you.
He's high level.
Good.
He learned it from all the teenage
girls.
He fucks allegedly.
Okay.
Allegedly I don't even have an opinion.
I haven't alleged opinion.
Uh,
my hacker thought my hacker taught me a
lot.
Please contact me so I can hire you or
you couldn't find a piece of paper.
Really had to use a Ralph's shopping
bag.
Alright,
let's watch this and try this.
Yeah.
Oh,
his GP,
gp here.
GP coming at Ya [inaudible] come again.
Come again.
Should I be coming at you?
All right.
So how do you guys know that I was
hacked?
By the way?
This hacker dude is something else,
man.
He is crazy smart.
I learned a lot.
Hi.
Sounds like such a fucking,
he sounds like he's 15.
Why does he talk like that?
He reminds me of the guy.
Isn't there a character in like fast
times at Ridgemont high played my
matthew mcconnery mcconaughey.
Hey,
he's like a 30 year old that hangs
around looking confused.
Yeah.
What,
what does,
what's that great line?
He,
he had to ride out,
ride out.
Oh,
there he is.
I had it ready to go.
He has a line.
He goes,
I get older,
but they stay the same age.
Something that's what he loves about
high school girls was the line.
He pretty much,
is that correct?
Um,
you know,
hacking is actually in adult way of
bullying.
What do you think about that?
I thought that was kind of interesting.
Hacking is actually an adult way of
bullying.
Is this saint him saying he thinks he's
been bullied,
right?
No,
we need to call a trump's life.
Where is coming from when that statement
really is a little bit but,
hmm.
Okay.
And when do you think,
I don't know.
I just thought it was funny thing.
He's being bullied.
Poor guy
and uh,
you know,
I don't know why the guy does it because
he doesn't get any real recognition for
it.
He's not really messing up my life that
bad cause my life.
I'm just not that important.
But um,
I've learned a lot from,
I learned about some ways to prevent
hacking and all this stuff.
But Dude,
if you're out there,
I want you to reach out to me.
The guy still has my aol
sound like his password was like
password.
I learned a lot about security.
Greg Paul rules still has his aol
account.
Oh,
I missed that.
Wait,
I can't rewind it.
You back my aol account and Cooney or
information here cause I want to hire
you.
Of course Craig Paul uses aol wants to
hire the hacker throwing to jail.
I think this was probably an elaborate
ruse to,
to get them,
this was his mastermind,
but you know Greg,
Paul probably still has aol dial up on
autopay.
You know what I mean?
I read,
I read a stat that there's like a
million people still paying all on a
dial up.
Like all these old people that never
upgrade their internet.
They're all like,
I bet you my grandparents,
he's like 94 still pays aol for
dialogue.
We can use your smarts in and your skill
set in a positive way and probably make
you a shit ton of legit money.
Anyway,
a hope you guys have a great weekend.
Those were the two fingers.
I'm just telling you honestly.
He did this and boy,
I saw those fingers and a bucket of
pissed.
You ready to come again?
Anyway,
I feel bad for him.
Hackings no fun.
It is adult bullying.
You're right.
I feel bad in a way.
I hope that girl was at her age.
All of those hackers.
She's such a nice male bullying.
Oh,
so now you agree.
I agree.
I came,
I came around.
It's adult bullying.
It's,
I don't know.
it sucks.
It's the worst thing you have to go
through.
It is awful.
And it's like,
yeah,
it's awful.
Anyway,
my heart goes out to Greg Paul and um,
it gushes for him.
You might say my heart scotches from one
might say that and I really hope the
girl was not under age for his sake.
For all of our sick,
for the world's sake,
please greg,
don't be fucking underage girls in
recording it because like where the
world is just not ready for that.
The Paul's aren't ready for that.
Youtube is not ready for that.
Greg,
please my heart gushes for you though.
You ready to come again?
All right.
All right,
so we can wrap it up from here.
Apparently the hacker said,
um,
what is the hacker said that they have
way more amped up evidence that they've
fought it to the FBI.
But yeah,
who knows what?
All of a sudden they have a conscious,
you know,
so there you go.
Um,
Greg,
I mean Greg is smashing though.
You came out here.
He's Jake's manager.
He's apparently yes.
And it's Nick Crumpton left.
Greg is taken over the mantle and he is
a mashing dude.
You need me to play that again?
Okay.
Uh,
moving on.
Post Malone is cursed.
You guys,
you may have heard the recent reports
that,
first of all y'all heard about how his
plane took off and the wheel blew up on
takeoff.
They had to emergency land.
Thank God post Malone was okay.
Next up,
the next couple of days he's in a car
crash or someone driving a quarter
million dollar Rolls Royce,
a car crash thing.
God,
he's okay.
Got Blessed.
The suite are of that man and then an
armed robbery took place at his old
house.
That place we've been to I,
if it's the place I'm thinking of,
which I think it has to be,
we've been there a lot of times.
That's scary.
Armed robbers show up at the House
asking more post Malone is terrifying
and I'm so glad that post wasn't there.
He had since moved and the tenants that
were living there got stood up at
gunpoint.
They stall like 20,000
year.
There was some things,
jewelry.
So I'm,
I'm,
I'm so glad that Austin was in there
because he's a kind of,
we don't call nine one,
one kinda guy.
You know what I mean?
That would have been some,
some gunfire.
I have a bad feeling.
But at any rate,
what is going on with Post Malone?
Well,
we think we have the answer guys.
We think we've figured it out.
And of course it's TMZ who was put the
pieces together.
Um,
posting them messing with evil spirits
on video now curse plane and car makes
sense.
It all makes sense.
Finally,
this Guy Zach from ghost hunting.
These guys are so funny.
You know how I feel about goes something
postmodern loves it though.
So apparently,
um,
there's this,
uh,
Zach tells us the closing encounter went
down in June and is haunted museum.
The object is called the Dubuque Dbu
box.
Dbu Is Yiddish for malicious spirit and
the box inspired the horror flipped
position,
really yiddish.
So they're saying that Jews are behind
all of it.
Great.
It's another Jewish conspiracy.
So explain what is this?
So this box,
this Guy Zach,
the ghost hunter.
It's apparently the most cursed item in
the world because they're Jewish ghosts
and they got it.
They have a chip on their shoulder.
Yeah,
there's videos for this is it dude?
You got,
Oh fuck.
Let me fuck.
What the fuck dude you got?
That's kind of dope.
Think about that.
It's like,
um,
of all the cursed objects in the world,
you got Kirsty Gypsy shit,
cursed Polish Shit,
cursed whatever.
German shit.
Yeah,
it's the Yiddish ghost.
They're the most gnarly.
The Jewish goes.
So the ones you absolutely do not want
to fuck with.
That's kind of it up.
So here's the video that explains
everything that's been going on.
I want you guys to,
that's a,
at his house or something.
It's that it's haunted museum and I
think Vegas,
so this is the first time he's actually
apparently taken the box off or touch
the case itself as the story as opposed
to,
and is freaking out.
And he's like,
don't do it.
But that's where postmen fucked up.
You see?
See Zach,
the ghost hunter knows what he's doing.
He knows how to handle a curse.
He talks to the box,
the first one ever to do it.
Awesome alone.
Being the sweet guy.
He tried to break them away from the
box,
but curse was transferred to them.
In that moment.
The lights are off obviously for s add
spooky effect.
Did like,
you know,
we could have the lights on but let's
leave him off.
Um,
this is the curse.
Djourou what's with the star of Davids
and like,
you've got like a Torah and shit.
What is this?
Some kind of fucking Jewish fun house.
Yeah,
Austin's freak the fuck out.
He's trying to get out.
Oh,
he turned on the lights.
Thank God Austin.
Oh wait man.
Yeah.
He just turned on the light here.
You can see,
I'll go back.
He goes back to the door.
He's like,
fuck this turns on the lights.
Zach is trying to play it cool.
Like he doesn't care.
Um,
but here he goes in Austin's like,
dude,
this is a,
this isn't just any ghosts.
This is a Yiddish goes cause also knows
better.
You know,
we went,
when we went go something with Austin,
he was very respectful.
He was very cautious about the spirits.
He really,
he believes this stuff and he was not
fucking around,
so I know that he's,
he's deadly serious about this stuff.
No,
there was the thing where when he,
when he opens the door,
I think there's like something moving
out of the lefty.
We'll play by play,
but first let's hone in on that.
But first,
let's see what happens.
So often it's freaking out.
He's got a beer in hand.
He's trying to talk Zach and to getting
out.
He's hyper ventilate,
he's breathing heavy.
He's grabbing him.
He's saying they run out of the room now
post malone being the sweet guy he was,
he took the curse from Zack and these
old yiddish.
She goes,
you know what I need to do?
I think I can resolve this.
What,
because these yiddish ghosts,
they need a good Jewish boy to come talk
sense into them.
I think I can channel maybe these
yiddish ghosts and lift the curtain.
Curse the curse.
No,
no,
no.
I am a good Jewish boy.
I'm well fed.
That is all yiddish grandmother ever
wanted.
I'm a good sweet bar Mitzvah and I think
that I can talk some sense into these
shooters goes,
should I say a prayer?
No,
I think I should say a prayer to lift
the curse.
Uh,
can you pipe me in some,
a prayer,
a prayer.
Spooky.
Yiddish prayer.
Music.
Should I have that?
Um,
this is maybe appropriate.
No,
no,
this is too sad,
isn't it?
Um,
angelic music.
There's no,
there's angels in Judaism,
right?
No,
no,
no.
For Christ Sake,
curse on you.
Get curse on you,
right.
Uh,
yiddish spirits.
What was it?
What were they called?
They were called the [inaudible].
They did book the Debug,
debug spirits.
Cursing Post Malone.
He's a good boy.
He's a good sweet boy.
He loves his parents.
And is this the prayer?
Yeah,
it is not fair.
This is my prayer.
I'm trying to banish the,
trying to banish the Yiddish goes.
He eats well and I've cooked lockers
with aunt for him on several occasions.
We spend tradle on Hanukkah together.
Me and Austin have spun tradle and you
are going to curse this good Jewish boy.
How dare you.
Austin comes from a good family and was,
and also he loves Hala Bread.
I know that because I've shared Hala
bread with him.
If you can lift this curse yiddish
spirits,
Dave Lik,
what is it?
[inaudible] book the Book and return to
your box.
Then this Jewish boy will be forever
grateful that I'm a bar Mitzvah.
Amen.
As this.
So I need this adventure of like,
eh,
their book boxes on Ebay and really,
and they all look so weird.
It does it.
One,
he lives on the fucking search for some
d book.
Get some Debo Cup in here.
Let's order one here.
All we can buy the shit on it.
Well,
what's so special we can buy the shit on
Ebay.
Kid made haunted debug book box,
20 bucks.
Real shit alone.
I feel like I'm getting curse just
looking at it.
That is going on with heart wrenching.
Um,
Shit.
there is a more in debt related items.
Like what is this?
Can you play,
play any music playing any music?
Cause I seriously want to get rid of
this curse.
I care a lot about post malone.
If God's d book goes out there,
lift the curse on postage alone,
I will make him eat a hundred bowls of
Matzah ball soup.
I swear to you now on the body of Moses
and the burning Bush itself.
Okay?
I will spread any scene of [inaudible]
to fish if you will.
Just lift the curse on the sweet young
post Malone.
He doesn't deserve it.
He looked back me up.
Yes.
Amen.
We will spin draco.
We will eco filter fish.
We will share in the good times of
Matzah ball soup.
He's a sweet kid.
He doesn't deserve this.
You're an old Jewish lady.
You got a chip on your shoulder.
Get some therapy and the afterlife.
There's somebody out there that can help
you.
For Christ's sake.
Don't take your disappointment and your
grandchildren out on
Milan.
All Jewish grand parents are
disappointed in their grandchildren.
That's light.
Be at Peace Day book,
be at peace.
Beautiful,
calm first would appreciate that I
really powerful stuff.
Do it.
I think I left the curse.
I felt there was a change in the,
uh,
felt that there was a change the spirit.
Meanwhile,
I dunno.
I felt like maybe Austin Prob,
I think he owes me.
Um,
can we show them,
and I notice this very spooky moment
here.
I read it in the comments,
but soap go ahead of you.
And when he opens the door,
was it there off the top right to the
point where he opens the door at the
top.
There it goes.
There's something that flies out of the
room side right here where my mouse is.
It flies all the way from here out the
door.
Yeah.
Watch this.
When he opens the door,
you see that?
Did you see that?
I see,
I see.
I'm telling you.
Gook fest,
2000 and fucking 18.
Hey right here.
One more time.
Watch it comes from the left side of
screen out the door.
There it goes.
A white light.
Now,
a reasonable explanation.
Bhag bug.
It could be the reflection on that door
reflecting off the camera or something
like that.
You know what I mean?
But most likely it's a d book that came
in and infected the whole fucking
planet.
So I need to say another blessing.
Everyone's like,
fuck no.
All right.
Well anyway,
my first thought was like,
seriously,
the Jews are behind this.
Yeah.
Blame the Jews.
Typical.
I can believe this items.
We just found it on Ebay.
All right,
well up next we've got the Nadoo weather
reporters.
All their coverage of this hurricane was
outlandish in insane and hilarious,
so stay tuned.
We will be right back after this short
words from our sponsors through my
mouth.
Stitch fix has reimagined the way we
find and buy clothing.
Here's what stitch fix is.
You go to their website,
you fill out a questionnaire.
You tell him what's your budget?
What kind of guy are you an a stylist
springs into actual,
your virtual mom or girlfriend does a
little shopping for you and sends it to,
okay.
Now that's convenient enough as it is,
but here's the thing,
if you don't like it,
you don't keep it.
If it doesn't fit,
You send it back.
Boom.
It's so convenient.
That's it.
You know?
Uh,
some guys can't dress and let's face it.
One of those guys is Dan,
our producer.
He's a sweet guy,
but he started using stitch fix.
Unlike me,
I'm Mr Swab.
I always dress great psych.
That's isla the dress.
Dan.
On the other hand,
I always dress like an idiot.
What am I even saying?
Dan,
on the other hand,
love stitch fix.
He uses it all the time and he can't put
this hoodie down,
Dan,
to tell him about how much you love
stitch fix.
It's just unbelievable.
It's changed my whole life since.
A little irony there,
Dan,
but I know that you're not being ironic.
You're being genuine because it was a
great service that I recommend everybody
try.
This stylist fee is only $20 which is
applied as a credit towards anything you
keep.
So guys,
hurry to stitch fix.com/
[inaudible] and get started right
freaking now because if you keep all
five items in your box,
you get 25% off your purchase.
Go to stitch fix dotcom slash h three
rings.
Mission is to make neighborhoods safer.
I love ring.
I've been using this product for years
and for me it's changing the way that
home security works.
You've got to ring what it,
first of all,
it started with the doorbell.
You clicked the doorbell,
it makes the noise inside of like a
normal Doba but it's also got a camera
and a microphone.
So if somebody's been creeping on your
doors,
stealing a package,
whatever it be asked Shenanigans,
they're up to.
Not only does it record them based on
motion,
but it zaps the recording up to the
cloud and saves it forever.
That means that they're not getting
away.
I mean you can talk to them.
You can tell him,
hey buddy,
why f exactly you?
Oh now we're talking home security now
here,
let me tell you about,
they've got rink flood lights,
these things are awesome.
I got them sold in our house.
It's so great.
It's a flood light and motion detector
and a video camera offers the same
thing.
You could bless them with a siren too.
It's incredible.
And they've got this thing on the app
called neighbors and like all your
neighbors within like a two or three
mile radius upload videos of shenanigans
going on at their house.
It's like a little community and it's so
great.
Like there's these old ladies that post
videos of like delivery guys that are
going to the wrong door.
They're like,
this guy was ringing at my door at 8:00
PM does anyone know who him and
everyone's clowning on?
The old lady like it's a delivery.
It's a delivery.
Like really?
Is this what this apps come through?
It's Hilarious,
but there's some good stuff there too,
but it's a lot of entertainment and
besides the entertainment,
it's great security guys.
They cannot endorse this product enough.
As a listener,
you've got a special offer on a rink
starter kit available right now with a
video doorbell and motion activated
floodlight Cam.
The starter kit has everything you need
to build a ring security around your
home,
so go to [inaudible] dot com slash h
three that's a ring.com/h
three I love this product.
I use it personally.
I endorse it.
You pick this up,
you're going to love it.
ring.com/h
three seek geek.
You know him.
You love him.
You need tickets to a place.
Do it with seek.
It's easy as that.
You're going to see a sporting event.
Siki you're going to see a music concert
seeking.
Are you going to watch Jake Paul live in
concert and want front row seats so you
can get squirted on by his dad?
Siki skies,
they've got you covered on everything.
Okay,
now,
um,
there,
here's what's great.
One to 10 score.
Look at the seat.
They'll tell you straight up,
no bs,
one to 10.
If it's a good score,
green is good,
red is bad.
I mean it's basically you see the view
from the seat.
Boom.
There's no surprises.
It's just a good,
reliable place to get tickets upfront.
Honest,
here's the best part and I got to tell
you,
there's no kicker here.
We got to hookup for all you guys.
Use Code h three h three for 20 bucks
off your first order.
Just click the me tab on the APP and
enter code h three h three for $20 off.
Guys,
this is not,
this is them just handing you 20 bucks
to go see a live show.
It doesn't get better than that.
And frankly you might even catch a
little bit of a Greg Paul's fluid on
your face,
so I say that's a buy and not take me in
for two.
Please check the link in the scription
to download the APP.
Remember guys use code h three h three
for $20 off your first seek order.
It's honest,
it's great.
It's straightforward.
You need tickets seeking.
Scott,
you covered.
Quid is a totally free app for Ios and
Android can collect stickers,
gifs,
cards,
3d toys for free.
All on your phone.
Stickers from shows like rick and morty.
Bob's Burgers,
games of thrones at Disney,
marvel Naruto.
Oh Shit.
Naruto how do you say Naruto?
I always say it wrong.
What's the wiebe away an hour ago,
not hotel.
I don't know.
Even our Buddy Jack Film.
Yes,
that's right where the F F is.
My stickers.
Jack film as sick as I don't have
stickers.
Plus they're updating,
adding new stuff all the time.
You can then trade them with your
friends or even text them and I messaged
by dragging and dropping them into your
messages.
There are a ton of shows and influencers
in there.
I remember it's totally free.
Some of the packs and box opening are
super rare and you can meet other fans,
acquit and trade with them to complete
your favorite sets.
Try Your best rank on the leaderboard
for every given set.
As you can see here,
it's all playing out before our eyes.
It's all free guys.
The items,
it's all free.
The APP is free.
You get more coins every few hours.
And if you want more you just watch an
ad or you pay to get a couple more coins
so you can get some more stickers.
So follow the link in the description of
this episode of the download the APP
from either the apple or android store
and start collecting your favorite
stickers today.
Thank you.
To quit.
Get trading boys.
Welcome back.
Nutty weather reporters.
This has been a phenomenon that's been
going on.
Um,
these reporters,
they send them out and to hurricanes and
treacherous weather crap out crack open
here is 30 pounds and they make these
poor sons of bitches basically brave,
dangerous wins.
And sometimes the ones they're not that
dangerous so they have to hype up the
danger themselves.
We've got a little of each got a little
off but what was the name of this recent
hurricane?
Florence.
That's right.
So uh,
you guys may have heard there was one
particular gentlemen,
um,
that was called out all over the
Internet for his uh,
Hurricane Florence meme and this guy was
out in the weather channel and it's kind
of this classic story of acting like the
weather's insane.
And then somebody walking through the
back wall here.
I'll let you watch.
All right.
Now,
first of all,
worth noting is I'm leaning in North
Carolina right away from the where the
wind is blowing.
Like that doesn't make any sense.
People have said that maybe he's
covering the microphone,
but that doesn't really make sense to me
cause you can see as it goes on,
he's clearly not covering the
microphone,
just whipping through here.
More heavy rain.
Well they have that.
Woo.
He's trying to brace some stuff though.
That is a pretty healthy cusp right
there.
When you have fun anyway,
here in the beginning you can see a
couple of dudes just strolling as casual
as possible.
Okay.
And Wilmington,
North Carolina,
right at the intracoastal.
And we're in one of these bands.
This is just literally scrolling by and
Patchouli as possibly do I love
sneakers.
There's truly no problem balancing.
We're 60 miles an hour.
Yeah.
So there you go.
Who would I thought that only on
Youtube.
I thought people exaggerate and right
quick money.
And these are like real professional
weathermen is it like scientists?
That's what I'm saying.
You set up these atmospheres and
everybody will be reduced to a
clickbaiting Nice Smr,
spaghetti con of Jesus Christ.
I click on it starts again.
So anyway,
people got really upset by this,
um,
overdramatizing of how bad it is.
I find it just funny.
It's like,
damn,
you're out there bracing yourself the
wrong way.
And um,
anyway,
the other excuse I heard,
is there anything to this that it's that
Oh,
well he was,
um,
he was standing on grass is why.
Yeah,
I've got that from the,
I'll,
I'll read that later.
That man,
while I have a statement from the
weather report,
they defend him against the claims and
I,
I'm,
I've got it all laid out.
I want to enjoy some more footage of
this guy bracing against the
treacherous,
whether raw cane and we're getting gusts
pushing God still.
So it goes without saying the
categories.
Sometimes we're misleading with
hurricanes where the wind is whipping
through here.
More heavy guys,
40 miles per hour.
Hold on there by hold on there that you
have to lower your center.
Hold on there by like on top Bronco or
some shit.
Anyway,
so we've got a whole thing here.
Let's see what we got.
So this guy got into a bunch of,
of,
uh,
stuff and weather channel made a
statement.
They're supporting their boy.
They're not leaving them out in the
trenches.
They said,
yeah.
And they got his back.
You know,
whether people,
the weather people,
they,
they're a tight knit community.
They said it's important to note that
the two individuals in the background
are walking on concrete.
And Mike said l they name him.
They name him and shame him first and
last name.
And Mike settle is trying to maintain
his footing on what grass after
reporting on air until 1:00
AM this morning and his undoubtably
exhausted.
Well,
I mean Mike counter is just stand on the
concrete.
How has done the on grass changes?
Anything I haven't noticed.
It doesn't on growth.
It doesn't really that much.
They those,
yeah.
I don't know.
It doesn't really.
Um,
but the weather,
the weather channel,
they love this hurricane shit.
They go crazy this day.
They blew their entire production budget
for the whole year.
They put together these insane three d
renders where these reporters stand and
like a severe with a massive crazy green
screen and they show you virtually like
where are the water heights are,
will be.
And it's just so over the fucking top
for what I,
it's amazing.
It's really cool.
But they're all just so jacked about
these hurt hurricanes.
And here let me show you born to bring
kind of crack.
It's kind of crap.
Look at this shit.
That certainly is enough to knock you
off.
Beat.
Definitely stole cars out.
Even carry cars away as certainly flood
many of the lower levels of structures,
but we know Florence is also going to
bring water.
It's water.
Yeah,
no,
six feet of water.
Imagine that.
Imagine the add on,
for example,
the technology of the weatherman that
would otherwise be and also tommy cause
higher and where else can we use this
technology?
Oh,
it goes even higher.
I go,
you said it perfectly reminds me of like
the facebook,
the ducker cruise through Puerto Rico,
the Puerto Rico life's trainer,
fish in the water.
Why the fuck is that realistic?
Cover up one story.
Buildings and structures and the
details.
Mather,
anything that's certainly pose a risk to
many.
There are very few places so he wouldn't
be that.
Now that is like,
man,
he's underwater.
They didn't even tell his ass.
It's a wall.
That wall.
Follow the advice of your local
officials and he viewed that black
thing.
It's the garbage bag corpse and I bet
that's selling.
You know,
the intention is good.
Heed the advice and get the hell out of
there.
Don't get washed away.
Okay.
Don't braved the storm.
You know,
it's funny,
I find ironic.
All of these weather reporters are like,
do not braved the storm.
Everybody evacuated and meanwhile I'm
going to do right.
No one's blown away and listened to me.
They tried to justify staying because
it's so stupid.
By over reacting and acting like till
like shit,
nothing's happening.
There's another clip of a girl I love.
I love these clubs.
It's just,
it's incredible.
Loved their enthusiasm for hurricanes.
Florence is a large and extremely
destructive hurricane.
Storm surge is going to be potentially
life threatening for some areas along
the u s coastline and this morning we've
seen the water picking up over some of
the roadways.
Let's go ahead and take a look at what
could be a reasonable worst case
scenario for areas along North Carolina
all the way here from surf city to North
Topsail beach,
we could be talking about up to six feet
of storm surge and again impacts have
already begun today with the storm
approaching even inland.
It's not just going to be a coastal
event here,
areas along the river and that we can
show you what this could look like if
you were to find yourself in this
scenario.
Once that water comes in three feet,
you can see it on my shins,
my waist.
This could be enough to knock you off
your feet.
You can eat another guy at the far side
of the roadway.
This is extremely dangerous to that six
foot range.
How high this water goes.
Ooh.
Wins pick everything.
Yeah,
they did.
They got a little choreography with it
yet no powers
stand here.
Even withstand the force of the water
coming in.
No Shit.
But anyway,
I thought that was great.
I love that.
Love it very much.
And then of course there was,
of all things,
like you said,
they probably blew up all their budget.
They have a production budget that they
blow one week,
the next toy there point is going to be
on like the cell phone camera.
Yeah,
exactly.
They don't,
they can't afford cameraman anymore.
Then of course there was,
um,
ludy interestingly,
of all places,
a dollar store was alluded.
If you're gonna I mean a dollar store
looters [inaudible] dollar store
looters,
that's gotta be,
I mean,
that's rock bottom money shit.
Dot loot somewhere else.
At least if you're going to break the
law,
could something more valuable than a
neiman marcus or something?
Come on.
Yeah,
no.
Anyway,
let's watch a video.
This reporter is 13th and very brave.
What are you getting there?
Entering the cup,
right?
Kitchen towels.
A couple of kitchen towels,
some juice,
some,
some cheap oil.
That's useful.
Uh,
you know,
you could get there.
You could steal a 10 pack of sporks.
What does park?
It's a,
it's a fork spoon combination into one
utensil.
Oh,
there's some fancy sporks actually have
a knife on the side that's outside of,
that's the two.
That's,
you can't find that kind of quality at
the dollar store though.
Um,
is anyone else that sat at the dollar
store and not everything costs a dollar?
Shouldn't even be,
I think because you know it doesn't
upset me because I know that you,
I would go shopping in those stores and
then it's what I want is like 15 $15
that no,
that's too far.
Yeah.
If you have a $15 item in the dollar
store close up.
I'm alluding is what I'm at.
I'm alluding your dollar store.
I understand in this day and age is 2018
we've had a flesh and if you,
you can kick it up to two or three bucks
for a really premium,
I'm talking about a spork with a knife
up the side.
You can charge a premium for that.
No,
I remember even in Israel we have both
stores and it's like a shotgun store
that's 25 cents by the way.
But then what I want would be 20
shaking.
Oh give me a fucking break.
Yeah you make a scene.
Do,
do row stuff.
Do you yell and you know I just only by
the the shaking and stuff.
Okay.
What do you buy for a shekel?
That's the only 25 cents.
I used to love buying stickers there
cause they would have like really weird
Chinese knockoff stickers when like how
much money we're looking.
Well that's what these people are
stealing cars.
This is a dollar store.
So it's fun and interesting.
I catch hell if I feel bad because it's
like pure desperation.
They might need food.
I mean how desperate are you if you're
stealing shit from a dollar store,
I don't know.
Go for it.
I say really?
You say loot the dollar store.
That's still illegal activity.
I feel bad.
I feel bad for emergency.
Someone owns that store out.
It's kind of drizzling.
Dan.
I'm not going to say that this is a life
or death situation,
particularly quip.
It's a little bit,
but you never know.
But I'm saying like if you're,
if you're,
if you're alluding a dollar store,
you're not like,
you know,
set for life.
I mean you might be able to enjoy those
stickers.
If you own a dollar store,
you're not set for life.
Depends is it a chain is a mom and pop's
dollar stores have dollar tree.
Dollar tree can get looted the fuck out
of it.
Yeah,
that's fine.
Yeah.
Damn.
And when did,
when did you become such a vigilante
Jesus Christ?
Amen.
When it's an emergency.
I know I did not.
I just remember we never did a
background check on dance dance like a
police murder.
Anyway,
wash the bravery of this lady and she
confronts these awful dollar store
criminals in the wake of this awful
tragedy.
It's a national emergency.
I want to identify what they're
stealing.
So this guy's got a 12 pack of coke,
zero by the way.
Excellent taste young man.
That's actually,
those are mini cans.
It looks like maybe a six pack of mini
in the dollar store.
Ralph's.
Those run about three bucks.
So $3 but if it's a six pack of mini
cans,
you might be able to get those for a
buck.
They're probably expired,
obviously.
Excuse me.
Do you know that you're stealing a six
packs of coke?
Zero.
Excuse me.
What does she think?
You're caught committing an act of
crime.
You're supposed to stop and do a little
interview.
You know what I mean?
Can we see your face please,
sir?
And uh,
your name and phone number and address.
I'm really curious about both feeling or
you know,
your lips.
Wait,
the kid playing.
I went,
oh,
I'm just try.
I really want to identify what they've
gotten.
The car correct.
He's got what looks like a tub with like
maybe some detergent.
Well,
tupperware.
I mean,
look,
if you're willing to steal detergent.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
Chris Stealing is stealing folks on
that,
right?
Just say it.
You know that you're alluding and
the law in and compromise everything I
stand for as a human being to get a free
six pack of coke.
Zero expired.
Yes.
You can see people coming out apple
juice with items left and right from the
store.
It's like when you're in class and new
kids are cheating on the exam.
She's like the kid that's like,
I see you guys.
She's a nurse.
She's a fucking snitch is what you mean?
Yeah.
I see.
Nobody wanted,
they like candles.
There's a full shelf of like candles or
like something on the,
we'll get this star.
Yeah,
that's like trash.
He's so concerned.
I can go back around front guys.
Right?
I mean,
there are no books.
She's truly brave law enforcement
onsite.
Oh Shit.
No law enforcement.
Excuse me sir.
Um,
what are you going to be doing with
that?
A small can of tomato paste talking to
me.
All right,
look across the street here.
People are filling up what looks like
laundry bags full of items.
Wow.
Running.
It's a mass mixer here.
And let's go back to the front crystal.
Excuse me sir.
What are you trash bags.
You are stealing a,
what are those toy guns with like little
car.
Anyway,
this is a,
this is what's the worst of the worst
than these hurricanes folks.
People
expensive.
This is the worst of the worst at this
is as bad as it gets.
Huh?
Thanks.
Think I,
they ain't losing your house.
There's people that some for kids taking
like a six pack of paper.
They just on the ground.
This is as bad as it gets walks.
Meanwhile,
people are fucking dead.
Their houses floating down anyway,
it's all funny.
It's all funny.
I'm not saying Ludy not defending allude
in,
uh,
at the situations.
Hilarious.
They're alluding a dollar store.
You got this reporter that thinks she's
like on the ground in Vietnam or
something.
You know what I mean?
Did the worst and these hurricanes
folks,
uh,
people getting desperate looking for
items looks like they've just busted
completely through the door here.
I would watch,
I could watch,
I swear to God can wash worship,
I don't know,
30 minutes.
I love that clip.
Cool.
Wonderful stuff.
Really great stuff.
Um,
what else we got?
Uh,
manner of time.
Oh yeah.
So here's another bozo out and the storm
from the hurricane.
Now this guy,
yeah,
on the opposite end you've got do it
pretending to be in danger and then
you've got dude,
cause you send these reporters out when
sometimes it is actually dangerous and
this is one of those times
what is like fill it back to you.
10 before we let you go.
Some of these
tad,
before we let you go,
we want to make sure that you die
some of these different live shots.
Okay.
We've seen,
we've seen people wandering around a
little bit.
Are those reporters outcome rate or or
are you seeing residents in the area
just kind of coming out and taking a
look at things?
This morning I,
I've seen a couple reporters out driving
around,
but as we,
as we turn around now,
there aren't many that we can see.
They're starting to be a couple of the
people who have stuck around that
gentlemen down there.
And a yellow raincoat is a local land by
huge,
uh,
sheet metal is a little shock.
We're okay.
That was just not cut a little spoon.
You're going to be surprised and I think
he's ready to get out of there.
Yeah.
Oh,
it's good to go.
I don't know about this.
Go and I'm gonna let you guys go,
ted,
before you go,
uh,
can you tell us how did that feel
getting hit by a sheet metal?
Do you see any other debris flying
around?
He pulled that on him a tad before you'd
go.
You're not getting paid extra hour
regular.
Right.
I'm going to head out of here.
I'm going to let you guys go a Ted
before you go.
Can you tell me?
Do you see corpses around?
Do you see any other flying debris?
By the way?
The one thing that's always common in
these reporters out on the field,
they're getting blown away and acting
like the world's in chaos.
The camera man is standing there holding
the super heavy thing.
He never fucking budges,
you know that's true.
Okay.
Or you go,
not all heroes wear report her outfits.
Right.
Well Sadiola I give that as a word at us
were before you'd go ted,
can you uh,
go near any glass windows that are left
it up?
Bust out.
All right,
ted.
Oh,
looks like Ted got hit by a sheet metal
before you go ted.
Anyway,
good stuff.
Huh?
Do we have quality content here or what?
Um,
and then of course you've got some
classic ones that I wanted to share with
you guys.
You may have seen it,
but these are my favorite ones as well.
I mean,
this guy got in trouble,
but I feel like these guys kind of
goofed up even worse because,
well,
I'll,
I'll this,
he's in a canoe.
Okay.
For Christ's sake.
I love him.
The guy next door just like,
what the hell are we doing?
Every time it rains hard and there's
someone walking by ankle,
ankle high,
I really cut out quick,
but the next one's as good as against
here and let's pull this one out.
Ready?
They get a kind of new,
they brought it in.
The northeast is more rain,
continues to fall today and be c's,
Michelle Kosinski and a coo.
She's in a new way.
New Jersey this morning.
Michelle,
good morning to you.
She's got a paddle,
she's paddling in her canoe is there,
we're getting a nice break from the rain
but not the flooding.
And somebody would literally walk two
guys who are like fuck this lady walk
right in front of her.
And it's just at ankle depth.
And what I love about the reporters is
they call her out so great over in this
neighborhood.
Don't try to say,
well she was standing on a shoe stands,
grassy water.
Would they uh,
there was a deep point,
deep point,
well canoe or boat when you're out in it
as much deeper back here because this
actually Michelle,
I'll take it.
Is there some kind of severe drop off
there between the floor?
Go back.
This guy's a second shall walk in.
Are these holy men walking on top of you
guys when you have a ride like this,
why would you want to walk?
You run a short,
you know,
it's funny.
All
the producers are probably in on it and
they just tossed her ass bus hard.
By the way,
shout out to Matt Lauer who actually had
a button and is this is Matt Lauer?
Yeah,
the button guy.
He hit a button in his office.
He got me to his stories.
One of my favorites.
He gave him,
he me to it.
He didn't get me to it.
Right.
That's the term he got me to code.
He toured.
He too.
Yeah,
he too.
So He's,
he's is one of my favorite c and this is
crazy.
He had a button installed under his dad.
So when people are female interns or
whatever came into his office,
he had a button,
he would push that lock the fucking door
behind them.
Oh,
how do you even think about that?
That's like Dr Evil Shit.
A button that locks the door from the
outside.
Anyway,
good shout out to Matt Lauer.
How did they even explain that when he
was like ordering it?
You know like what do you put on the
work order?
Just put it on that.
What other men budget?
They got all that.
They'll get out of their special effects
budget.
Yeah,
deep water because they weren't.
All right,
I'm going to need a button.
Okay.
Now what this button does is it locks
the door from the outside so I can
really focus and get some work done.
Right now.
Well now it's for me to be able to
focus,
but just hypothetically,
if somebody wanted to get out,
they have to push this button under my
desk to get out.
Now that's just to make sure that I can
focus all the way that I need to.
Five years dreams,
piece of video there,
Michelle,
or hitting ground Michelle,
of course.
I wonder if he ever pushed the button on
her.
You know what I mean?
Michelle?
We stepped into my office.
Huh?
I'm writing about in there the button.
What do you read your motto?
Yeah,
talk to me and it turns out he did not
install it.
It was a mechanism that was a standard
feature in many of the older offices.
That was like the whole story.
You're debunking that.
Yeah.
Well what was the story?
What did he get in trouble for them?
Okay,
well it's more about the,
I think the actual personally yeah,
he raped somebody.
No,
I don't know what he did,
but sexual misconduct whenever there's
allegations,
but people were wondering about that if
he installed it personally.
Okay.
So he did it.
That's just standard issue for sit back
in the fifties yeah,
that was just standard.
It make it better.
Um,
okay.
Now moving on.
Hmm.
Shout out to Matt Lauer.
Hope he's doing good.
Wherever he is.
Be Company at Ya BGP mean inception 90
day fiance.
We all know and love this show very
much.
I'm a huge fan of this show,
so it's on the sub reddit.
There was a trailer for season six.
I have to tell you,
90 day fiance is one of the most
entertaining shows on television.
It is so insane.
It is.
So I don't even know how it's illegal.
Yeah.
To openly say to the United States
government,
I am coming with the intention of
emigrating.
That is like exactly what they say do
not do because it's illegal,
but it somehow tlc has figured it out
anyway.
And the trailer,
look what the fuck we found.
I've lost all respect for myself.
There's a flute Ba trooper here and
season six trailer wearing fucking hd
marriage.
I can't wait to see this the season.
Well,
I've got the trailer and I watched it at
all.
Yeah.
Here let's watch the trailer.
And I kept reading.
Do you want more information about them?
Tell me about Matt Lauer.
So the feature was a perk for top
executives who wanted privacy.
Oh,
personal calls or security.
But it's not clear how many people had
it.
And he was one
of very few,
if not the only one that had worn
whether weird story.
It did use it according to the
allegation that his,
so he used it.
It did use it.
You had it and he used it.
Allie allegedly.
That's crazy,
man.
Okay,
let's watch.
I loved that.
I mean a fucking button that locks the
door.
Christ sweet.
Uh,
what do we got here?
The trailer Tlc,
lovedale everything tells,
he makes this great.
The learning channel guys.
Cool.
In 90 days we're going to be husband and
wife.
You Rico,
people say girl,
maybe she couldn't be.
Maybe.
Have you watched to see maybe the
previous season?
I'm just a dysfunctional broke white guy
with no prospects in life,
but some beautiful girl from Brazil is
in love with me.
Maybe she's using me those five items.
Seasons of,
yeah,
maybe she's using me.
Maybe she just likes my personality.
Yeah,
right.
The,
the American guys are always like the
most like weird socially awkward broke.
No professional prospects.
Basically the most and data like very
undateable in my opinion,
if I was gay versus what,
Eh,
well,
you know,
an eligible bachelor.
No,
but what is it?
Is it was really American and then,
yeah,
it's always an American.
I think it's always an American guy.
Or is it?
Oh No.
Oh,
there was one really big girl.
Not,
I mean,
I'm not going to say that.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's not,
you know,
some people aren't did that.
Not me.
No.
It was a part of the story,
but she's a huge girl and there was like
a super fit guy from Columbia.
Yeah.
And he kept trying to get her to go to
the gym so he was not into that.
So she didn't want,
yeah.
Well yeah,
it's great man.
It's fucking amazing.
This show is like trauma city,
usaid.
So good.
Hello on vacation.
Lost my virginity.
And how has baby wow,
that's a lot.
She's beautiful.
She's sexy.
But his 90 days to get to know my
mother.
I live in the basement with my eight
year old mom.
She's beautiful.
She's sex,
she's a supermodel.
Maybe she's using me.
Maybe she just wants to come live with
me and my mom in the basement I were.
And also I work at a,
I deliver pizzas.
Not that they're,
I'm not degrading pizza drivers.
I'm just saying these guys have no
prospects.
We get it.
She's so eager to me in lab.
She's let's red flags.
If Jesus came down from heaven right now
and said he cheated on me,
I wouldn't do anything about it.
Finally,
there's also hope and romance as well.
The music takes age and I'm going to be
guiding in your bed day
romantic.
He every day and oh my God,
but so excited to finally see osweiler.
Oh whoa.
This shit is so good.
We're not going to tell me not to touch
my side.
I feel like a crazy.
What are you talking about?
What is this baby?
I'm a cat.
She walks into this guys house which is
full of garbage and flies and shit.
Welcome to heaven baby.
She might be using me ground,
so how concerned the life I have here
isn't enough for her to clean up before
it.
We're not getting a man.
He hasn't
and lady moved cross country
internationally.
Yup.
You can't even clean up all the Coffee
Cup.
Nope.
That's molding fee does not need as you
have.
Boy,
I've lost.
All right.
I love this.
We've got a sleeper,
so we've got asleep.
Oh yeah,
we've got a double agent.
The perpetrator.
Ah,
he's watching reach out.
Yeah.
Give us the email and dude,
God,
I love it so much.
What's it's been hard and it was
struggling.
Are you doing this because you have this
baby?
He's why I love these words.
Sure.
Like everyday apparently.
What is he one of the subjects or does
he like a brother?
Sister?
Yeah.
That's daddy's getting.
Got It.
Yeah.
That bitch is for his money period.
Anyway.
Oh my Jesus Christ.
Look at this Guy Craig.
I'm not saying that.
I mean that guy is not a catch.
I'm sorry.
All right.
Enough about this guy.
He might be,
he might be.
He's going to give her the d all night
long.
The point is that
it's generally one person is way out of
the other person's league.
Yeah.
And one person who is wade delusional
and one person has the opportunity to
give the other person where the League
of Isa.
Okay.
You guys get the fucking idea.
Um,
oh yeah.
Guys,
if you have any questions or you want
our opinion on something,
you want to show us something.
You want me to talk something,
email us.
I want to start answering emails every
episode.
So email
us@podcastaththreehthreeproductions.com.
What else we got?
Um,
yes,
some thing I've got the fat shaming
fashion revolve the drop.
Yeah.
There's a company called revolve,
which is a fashion company that teamed
up with Lena Dunham.
Actually,
I don't know what Lena Dunham and
thought.
So she comedian,
I just hear a name all the time.
Oh,
she's a writer.
Um,
at any rate,
she worked on a collaboration with this
company and it's a female empowerment
colab.
So the idea behind it was that they
wanted to make clothes that,
you know,
promoted body positivity.
So with that in mind,
let me show you what the final product
was.
Um,
so here you go.
Oh,
I can't,
I can't expand it.
That fun.
Sometimes it does what?
It does,
it definitely his fault.
Why is that?
So just zooming on the page.
Usually when you click it,
it just pops out.
That's,
sorry,
let me try refresh it.
Well,
any,
oh man,
that's kind of annoying.
Dad Page can write.
Try right clicking it and view image.
I'm not doing that.
So,
um,
here's a beautiful skinny model that
says two bony to be bombed.
So the idea was that they took quotes,
hurtful quotes,
and they used it as armor to be like,
Hey,
your words don't hurt me.
So horrible result of modern feminism.
Okay.
Slut feminist nightmare to bind to be
bond.
If you translated a bomb onto her face,
she'd have a better faith.
And of course here again,
being fat is not beautiful.
It's an excuse.
Imagine that one is the worst
[inaudible] girl that imagine wearing
that.
So people look at this $170 being fat is
not bad if fall,
it's an excuse.
Like Oh,
fit.
Yeah.
Oh,
so they missed the mark so much what
happened here?
Clearly I guess they meant the heavy,
heavier size.
Yeah.
You know,
it's still a weird shirt if I'm being
honest.
It is.
But this combination or are small,
right?
You cannot tell that it's a quote.
Yeah.
But either way,
the beautiful fit model was just a,
so people got so upset and everyone
wants the Xing,
apologies and whatever,
whatever.
To me,
this image really just is what I love so
much.
Being fat is not beautiful.
It's an excuse I earned 70 bucks.
So thank you to Lena Dunham and um,
we've all revolve for this
collaboration.
How we manage.
This is a really crazy on how we mendo
tell us Tyra Bank live on America's got
talent that she has fake hair.
Now I guess this is a somewhat common
thing of,
of females,
I guess black females have a lot of them
have fake hair weave.
We watch a whole documentary the Chris
rock made called like good hair or
something.
It was really interesting because I
don't think he made it.
Yeah,
I think it was Chris Rock.
Hmm.
And I didn't actually know this was a
thing,
but a lot of black women have fake hair
like from India.
So their hair,
they have like tiny little corn,
corn rows and then they weave real hair
of like straight or wavy hair and they
have like really elaborate weaves.
Apparently you're not supposed to touch
a black woman's hair.
Actually,
even a lot of white women have
extensions now.
So extensions.
Yeah.
No,
it's crazy.
Like extensions,
like I've seen it where you take the
extensions out and it's just like three
times as much volume.
It's like,
what the hell?
I don't really personally care that much
about the whole hair thing,
but the hey,
women want to feel beautiful.
They want to do their thing and got in
Boston anyway,
how we apparently knows because they
spend a lot of time backstage together.
The tyra has fake hair and so that
probably is what makes us even more
embarrassing.
So let us enjoy
the facial hair.
How does it feel with all that fake hair
on yourself?
I don't have no idea what that feels
like.
I don't care.
That wasn't a fake.
That was his real hair.
Oh,
I see what you did.
You see what she did?
No,
she has fake hair.
It's a Joe Walsh.
It's so bad.
Huh?
He genuinely thinks that she's setting
them up for like a,
a gag.
I don't know.
It was he thinking and is just really
trying to make a joke,
but it was so bad.
Well,
she said,
I have no idea what it feels like.
That fake hair.
Yeah.
And so he was like making a joke,
I think.
No,
but then I think he really was like,
oh my God,
what did I say here?
I'm in here watching.
She thinks it's a joke.
It's okay.
Okay.
I wasn't talking about her head.
You were like,
yeah,
I do.
I guess it's going.
This is live TV.
Okay,
we're moving on.
I know we have to move on.
Isn't this discussing?
Okay.
Ooh.
Tyra is not happy.
Yeah,
I mean it's,
I mean,
Shit.
I gotta watch that again.
Talking about her head.
That was an awful site,
by the way,
has fake hair.
It's a joke
that,
that this was real when he's like,
Whoa,
Shit.
Right.
In real.
What do you mean?
Well,
cause he was like,
oh,
I shouldn't have said that.
Yeah.
Of them.
No,
it's okay.
I think he was trying to make a joke,
but it was really the one wrong.
So tyra has fake hair,
to be honest.
I wouldn't have guessed it because
usually you can see it in the forehead.
I don't know.
That's a really good weaver.
She's rich.
She got that crazy fucking weeps.
Yeah.
You don't want it to be noticeable.
Sure.
But it's pretty,
I mean,
well,
so what the hell does it look like when
she takes her hair off?
Oh,
no,
you don't know about it.
I don't think you'd take it off.
I don't warn you when you go through
there Barbara,
you keep it on all the time.
Yeah.
And they fix it up.
You guys should watch this documentary.
Good hair by Chris rock is really
interesting.
Um,
Tara,
how are we fascinating stuff guys.
We've got great content here on the h
street podcast and you don't ever want
to miss a single episode because,
uh,
you just don't know what's coming next
and that radio.
Yup.
We don't even know what's coming next.
Nobody knows.
Guys,
have you seen this?
Um,
Joey Salads?
This is kind of a,
I don't know this,
I don't know when it's from,
but I love this.
I am.
I don't think I've watched it with you
guys before,
but vitaly sod,
Joey Salads at a gym and like,
uh,
confronted him because Joe said that he
wanted to fuck his mom or something and
it's just,
it's so priceless.
I got to tell you it's not racing
because vitale this days look like
Dragon Ball Z.
Does Eric there?
Oh Man.
Vitaly looks crazy.
No,
he says show afterwards.
It looks like Bruno from Ali G.
Well,
anyway,
here he is.
What up guys?
So I just walked in the gym and it
gives,
what a fucking seat.
I see Joey fucking the salads,
the big
Gino.
What the tally.
Don't fucking,
don't,
don't put disrespect on Joey.
Sal's name.
All right,
Joey Salads.
He's a guy.
You know what?
And that's fine.
You're fine.
It's the front of the show.
But uh,
he's got a lot of dressing on that
salad.
Me Disrespecting me,
my mother saying he wants,
my mother says he wants to fuck my
mother talking all this smack,
making videos online.
I'll walk into the gym at me.
You threw that up on the treadmill and
now he's gone.
I think he's in the locker room.
Why are you sending me Google Vitaly?
2018 that's the first result.
Well,
I got to talk all this shit.
What do you mean all the videos he made
sure.
Talking Shit about my mom.
The one video I made a year ago.
It's not a catchy boy band.
Walcott.
I'm in front of you right now.
What you're going to do about it?
You got to talk shit about me.
That old.
If he's got dongles.
When I was waiting for this moment to
happen,
I'm not to lie now.
I met you in person.
You're going to talk shit about my mom.
Have ever spoken anything about about
your mom?
No,
exactly.
So why would you fuck you?
Fuck you.
You should be.
No,
it's not jokes.
I'm here in front of you.
What you're going to say about it?
I got to say it's just stupid.
Youtube stupid.
Yeah,
exactly.
Because everybody who has something bad
to say about you on the call.
If I see him in person,
of course I will.
Of course I will because yeah,
and your boys not going to help you.
I'm serious,
I'll beat your fucking ass with my right
hand while I'm talking with my left.
And it's not petty.
You fucking disrespected my mother and
you don't disrespect it.
Well maybe in this country you can.
Not In fucking Russia.
Did I disrespect your mother?
I didn't need it to heat disrespectful.
You said you weren't.
And Joey does tend to think that
whatever he does on youtube doesn't mean
anything.
Like a fake black lives matter.
Trump car experiment.
He's missing.
I Dunno.
Oh my God.
Look at this picture of a tally.
Let me pull this up.
Villain Rocky or Dragon Ball Z.
Seriously look like man.
He looks like a suit.
Like,
yeah,
Ivan Drago and that's the,
that's the guy from rocky.
I mean he looks like he's on his way to
shoot a gay porn.
And I mean,
I don't mean to say like this is like,
yeah,
I mean he's got the bleached tips.
It's got the pink top
there.
You went to the muscles Ila.
I actually am not at all.
Thank God not to this level.
I don't.
What is the,
what's the good amount of muscle for
you?
Well there's some in his new vlog where
you were pointing out to me are today
were his big driving his car and his
dear friend is recording from the side
and his arm.
He's like taking up the whole screen.
What is that?
I just,
I get the feeling like when dudes get
this jacked,
they do it for each other.
I don't think that many women like
that's why I like trying to say bar
women with all the surgeries.
I felt like it becomes like a
competition between themselves and I
don't even think of the guys even care.
No,
I think so.
Like of course like a jack do with like
a six pack is attractive and looks good
and you like that.
But like at what point like here at Dan
just sent me this photo.
Like when you get like Mister Universe
jacked,
I feel like that's just the dude.
There's nothing wrong with him in the
before picture.
Okay,
that's great.
You're not,
you're an everyday man girl.
Um,
but at any rate,
I just,
I saw him,
he's like working out with all of his
dudes and they're all getting like
jacked as fuck and they're all like
checking each other out and they're all
like,
almost naked.
I was like,
this is gay.
There's nothing wrong with that.
But like this looks like,
you know,
God bless some,
maybe you'll find out something new that
is into something funny about that.
Just a bunch of naked dudes lifting boy
boyfriend joke had joe.
You're right.
He was like,
you and your boyfriend here,
Joey.
Is that what he said?
I think,
hey joey,
they might make a good couple.
I think they can make some really good
prank together.
And you know,
Joe,
he's no stranger to two gay porn.
He had a whole tumblr page for gay men.
I don't know if you guys know that.
He had this whole thing where he's
putting his dick in a hot dog bun and
putting like mustard on it.
And his roommate was recording it and
they started putting it on tumbler and
they had a whole huge following.
Oh my God.
It's news to me.
Beautiful following of a gay men
following him.
Yeah.
And I think at one point he just got,
he was like,
what am I doing?
Any ratio is a real variety man.
Yeah.
And I'll tell you,
and let me say something about Joey,
when he was any here,
I shook his hand.
He has the softest fucking hand lotion.
Like Bro,
I touched his hand and I was like,
what is your hands?
So Sasha and himself before he can't go,
I don't know.
You know,
you know,
do your thing and nothing wrong with
that.
I was gay.
I would suck so much dick like you.
Would you choose vitale or joey to would
I fuck.
Wow.
That's a fun,
that's a tough one.
Well I know vitaly can't even get it up
from the big bucks.
That is Joe.
He seems like he has a sweet thought.
If I'm being honest,
the tally seems totally unhinged and
insane.
Joey,
he seems to have a sweet soul and you
know those soft hands would,
would be,
would have me here in a split second.
So you're more of a personality I think.
Joey,
I think I'll go with jelly all day.
Joe,
if you're listening,
Jerry's going to cut part and upload it
to his channel.
H three wants to date.
Joey.
Stop.
Yeah.
I want to fuck Joe.
I put your Dick in a hot dog bun and a
damn split.
The damn second guys,
we have the best content here.
Do we not?
What else?
Goop.
You guys heard about,
oh,
you know goop.
We always make fun of goop when we do
like quick reads cause they say it's an
oprah is leads in goop and I was like,
what the fuck is goop?
Goop?
Gwyneth Paltrow,
the actress owns this magazine called
Coop and actually we've spoke about in a
magazine style.
It's a multimillion company lost.
First of all it's like what kind of name
is goop?
Apparently she has her initials,
Gwyneth Paltrow,
GP,
and she's like,
I wanted a name that meant everything
and anything and nothing.
I was like,
goop is a pretty literal,
that's just like a sound of like,
yeah,
it's like it's gross.
It's like when you take a shit when shit
comes out of your ass,
goop like that.
Sound effect.
You keep playing.
It's kind of pretty goopy type of a
good.
So anyway,
we spoke briefly about goop before
because they got in trouble for selling
stickers that were apparently and fused
with NASA technology to increase your
energy level.
And that's the total scheme.
What the fuck?
But now they're back.
They're being sued again because they
have vaginal eggs.
Uh,
jade eggs that you insert in your
vagina.
Fantastic stuff.
Let me pull up some pictures that are
appropriate for everyone.
You know,
I was more fascinated by this,
this egg.
Um,
I don't want you to see this photo
because it's really graphic.
Well,
here,
let me show you this.
So it's like an egg that you shove up
your badge and you keep it there like
all day.
It's crazy.
What do you think about that?
I mean,
I don't have you here.
I'll read it,
I'll read it.
I'll tell you all about it.
That was very uncomfortable.
Um,
here I've got the whole,
I got the low down here.
So here there's a picture of,
basically it's a drawing,
but I don't want to show it.
But you,
you,
you know what to do.
You know what?
You put it up there.
I'm like a Tampon I guess,
but except the giant stone.
Um,
from Kegels to vaginal steaming.
We're not shy here at goop.
Apparently not.
Apparently don't think much either.
We don't think much here at goop.
Why not?
I love this.
They call it a strictly guarded secret
of Chinese royalty,
queens and concubines.
Use them to stay in shape for emperors.
Jade eggs were said to harness the power
of energy work and crystal healing.
Shivah rose has been working with them
for about seven years and raves about
the results.
Jade Aix power to cleanse and clear make
them ideal for spiritual detox.
Hmm.
You still have any questions that does
that explain everything I'm jade eggs
can help cultivate sexual energy.
Clear Ci,
uh,
yeah,
cultivating,
intensify it and femininity and
invigorate our life force just to name a
few.
It's a holistic combination of things
where one benefits builds to another.
Jade also takes away negative energy.
It's a very heavy material and
incidentally it just shoves really
easily run up to your fucking badge
hole.
That's folder for them to write.
Um,
they did not.
Anyway,
this shit's hilarious.
I'm bummed it was just,
that all sounds great.
You can try it,
bro.
I got anal egg still works and stomping
is right.
Um,
how do we start and when you first get
your egg,
boil it right.
It's a sacred space.
They'll make sure plane for me it's
about physical cleaner.
You could put it under the light of a
full moon,
the clench or recharge it.
Oh my God.
What the fuck?
Or You could burn sage.
The egg does absorb energy.
So I like how they go from NASA energy
to Chinese,
I dunno,
uh,
Chinese secrets.
You know what goop is?
It's the sound that at jade egg makes
when a plops out of your vege.
Uh,
before I insert an egg,
I'll do our ritual.
I'll place it on a beautiful piece of
fabric,
light a candle,
and then shove it up my fucking nasty
snatch for my ritual.
I'll imagine pure light flowing from my
nasty snatch and shove an egg in there
who really expensive that's supposedly
likes,
I don't know anything it's due.
There's somewhere in there.
No,
no,
it's some,
it's some lady,
one of their editors I would assume
always rapped the egg and sell,
keep it clean and start on an altar on
the why.
It should take a sacred place in your
life and alter does that,
it's like a sacred podium and an egg
gets stuck or lost?
Good question.
I don't a good question.
This is the most common question we get
and no,
it cannot get lost.
Depending on the size of your cabin or
as cavernous giant vege it could get
lost for a couple of weeks depending on,
on uh,
how fast your vagina is.
No,
they say no it cannot get lost.
What about stock?
But there are ones that have a toll
drilled in them so that you can bungy in
and splunk into her vagina and follow
the lifeline to the egg.
Now you can put a through the egg and to
make it easy to take out.
Like way.
If you were to spelunk into a cavern,
know it's spelunking is that's cave
diving.
Yeah,
I remember that from the prank
conversion spelunking away.
Are there people who should not use jade
eggs?
Very good question.
If you're on your cycle,
do not use it out of people.
If you're pregnant,
do not shove that egg in there.
Okay?
A man,
if you have a function and brain,
do not shove it in I yeah,
exactly.
People will functioning bridge to not
use jade egg.
So there it is.
So what happened is that uh,
so what happened was that they're being
sued for basically making
unsubstantiated,
unscientific,
untested claims.
Basically everything I just read people
like less bullshit.
You cannot say that.
And they came into a and they're being
sued for it.
Oh Man.
Oh they did.
So yeah.
Why are you so familiar?
Because they paid one 50.
Oh,
they lost 145,000
so there you go.
I'm more,
I'm just more interested in the egg
itself.
That product is incredible.
How much is it?
It's like $70 70 bucks.
Not Bad for a not bad for a a rock that
you shove up your fucking ass hole.
Hmm.
It's nine to santee Iraq.
I got a couple of rocks.
If you guys want for 60 bucks,
you can shove up your house or they jade
or the recharge by the energy of the
moon.
Yes.
Oh fuck yeah.
I'll bet there's another headline.
Fortnight has been said it and more than
200 divorce proceedings.
That's it.
There's really nothing more than that.
And finally guys,
we do have an email.
If you guys have emails,
questions,
concerns,
you want to hear us talk about
something,
make sure to email
podcast@hdhdproductions.com
I have got an email to close up the show
today from a sweet young man named
Daniel.
Now,
Daniel,
like many of you out there are young
men,
impressionable minds who are looking for
answers and better ways to live,
a more holistic,
a natural life.
And he heard our discussion mine and um,
burt's about wiping,
how we wipe from the front that we march
to the beat of our own.
What we marched,
we marched from the front.
Others,
they wiped from the back.
The normal.
Well,
normal is a subjective term,
Mila.
And I want him to go that far.
I say a normal man.
The Standard Pazi body positivity.
So I'm going to read this email.
I thought it was a great email and I
wanted to share it with all you guys
and,
and it really,
and it created a new dimension on this
whole conversation about front wiping
verse back,
wiping something that I had,
which was an unintended consequence,
but a wonderful consequence of it.
So,
um,
let me begin here.
Dear Ethan,
for 25 years,
I have been a back wiping neanderthal.
Today I am proud to say that I have
thrown in the toilet paper and have
committed to front wiping moving
forward.
I was first introduced to front wiping
in high school when a participant on a
reality show reveal to his peers that he
wiped from the front.
I like the other people on the show was
disgusted by the thought of it.
It garnered the typical reaction that
most unenlightened people have where
they imagined smearing feces up their
ball sack.
Out of my own curiosity,
I tried it one day and confirm my own
suspicion that it wasn't insufficient
way of cleaning my ass.
And due to my naivety,
however,
oh due to my own naivety,
I now realize I was doing it incorrectly
by converting my own stand up,
back wiping technique to a front style
that was wildly uncomfortable.
Fast forward 10 years later and a big
fan of your show,
I was disappointed to be faced with the
issue.
Once again,
you spoke with Tom Sikora and Chris
Delea.
I found myself disagreeing with you as I
had an already settled this debate
myself as a teenager.
It was not until your episode with Bert
Kreischer that I was willing to give
front what being a second chance when I
learned that you remain seated through
the experience,
I realized I had made a mistake in my
past experience.
Then something that either you or bird
said really clicked with me.
It does not make sense to wipe a whole.
It needs to be a scoop in order to clean
and I do believe that was after this,
I was reading in three Coupe Ila please.
We're talking about scooping.
This is personal and spiritual.
After this I was ready to truly open
myself to change and why I'm wiping
technique.
While it felt a bit weird at first,
I have been blown away by the results.
First off,
it is more natural reach as opposed to
the awkward and standing up and reaching
backwards.
You don't need to stand up.
I stay seated.
A lot of people stand up.
You guys back there?
Do you stand up when you wipe from the
back?
Uh,
it's more of like a,
a slight lift and you left.
You left.
Well,
it's still technically seated.
I'd say somewhere in between.
It's a lift.
A lot of standalone wipe again can I
didn't get,
I,
this is emotional.
This is important to me.
First off,
it is more natural reach as opposed to
the awkward standup and reaching
backwards.
Secondly,
I'm able to perform a quick couple of
scoop scoop.
It's what he Rowan's when I said,
God damn it.
This is the truth as opposed to a rough
wipe that only makes the task harder as
you smear shit up your ass crack.
And lastly,
I'm able to finish in less wipes with a
cleaner result.
I just wanted to thank you for your
continued efforts.
If you are truly the Nelson Nelson
Mandela of wiping,
and I feel as if I am not the only
person to be converted by your wisdom.
I had doubts about this technique for a
decade and I can only think about all
the wasted time I've spent using an
insufficient,
inefficient wiping motion.
I recommend all back wipers give it one
week trial because the result is truly
life changing.
Thank you're sincerely.
10:00
PM I do not use baby wipes.
I've heard nothing but horror stories
about the dam.
Okay,
and now,
Yay.
You had me until you started talking
shit on baby wipes,
Daniel.
But you know I really wonderful.
I think I was moved because I was never
my intention to convert anyone ever
thought it was my,
as a misunderstood soul,
a victim of my own excess of wiping.
But I hope that it doesn't switch back
once he understands that it doesn't need
to stand up to wipe from the Mac did.
It's been wiping his ass his whole life.
He knows what he's doing.
Um,
interestingly,
Zack,
I just heard our sound guy,
he's our sound intern.
He's helping us out with sound.
Um,
he told me today that he in his house,
they don't even have toilet paper.
They go pure wet wipe,
which I've never thin.
I've never seen that.
And frankly I find it a little strange
because I would never,
I would never recommend a start wet
because that's just asking for trouble.
I recommend to Zach and to all anyone
else out there,
you have to take a hybrid approach
because you want to start try and what?
So Zach,
welcome aboard.
Pretty strange.
Zach,
do you wipe from the front or the back?
Can you talk into the mic method?
You serious?
Whoa.
First I was doing before,
but I tried it out and I happen to
really like it.
Wait,
are you fucking kidding me?
You're just saying that you want me to
bend over and yeah,
I don't know what that would prove.
I'm a cleat.
Wait,
wait,
Whoa,
let me get this straight.
Zach,
are you just saying this to get the job
right here or something?
He wouldn't lie about this.
He'll,
that's embarrassing.
It is very embarrassing.
But baby wipes and let me tell you,
save your life.
Hold on,
hold on.
Hold on.
Backup,
backup,
backup.
Hang on.
You're telling me that you wiped from
the bat until you heard this show and
then based on my anecdote,
you decided to lift your own balls and
Dick and one hand reach under them and
scoop out the shit from the front.
100% I cannot remember.
And you prefer it?
I do prefer,
yes.
Wait and wait.
And Ian is a front in.
I don't know that we've ever asked you
and where,
where do you wipe from it?
I think we did from the front seat.
And then then you're in back white boy.
Hold on.
Wait,
Dan is the odd man out here for one.
And then have you always wiped from the
front?
No,
I converted probably a high school.
Oh,
why did you convert?
What makes you say to yourself in the
middle of your life that you're going to
start lifting up your dick and balls and
scooping out shit from underneath it?
I didn't know that that was possible.
And then I think someone in a show set
it and I went,
what?
That's madness.
I tried it and I never went back.
And you think it's superior?
Absolutely bogus.
Truly a profit.
I'd been saying,
have you tried it now?
They know I did.
Yes.
No,
I gave it.
I gave it an honest go coop.
No,
there was some stupid,
I mean,
no,
I,
I want it to be objective.
You know,
I am like,
it.
Go into it without bias.
Didn't like it.
Now Dan,
tell me what you were sitting on the
John,
right.
And generally where I did my business,
but I just want to make sure you did the
technique right.
And then what?
Which hand did you wipe with?
Oh,
well I'm a righty.
So with the,
you lifted your balls and deck with your
left hand,
you remained seated a yes.
And then you went in with the right hand
in under underhanded,
underhanded technique.
Yeah,
that's how you do it.
I know,
I think I nailed it.
I think I nailed the technique and then
just,
I'm not a fan.
You may need to try it to the group mix.
Make an egg in there.
I'm down for that for sure.
Chuck.
Chris.
Well,
I have to tell you,
this was an eye opening.
This whole saga,
not only with sac,
a recent convert at that Ian Independent
and Ian,
he's a talented young man.
He'd say,
tell he's got a good head on his
shoulders and high school.
He said to himself,
there's gotta be a better way.
And he was converted from that first
scoop.
And I find that powerful.
We just found out two conversions in one
week.
Wow.
Who says he's amazing work here.
Important word,
incredible stuff.
And I thought that we were just talking
here,
wasting everyone's time.
No evil.
How many people are going to front scoop
tonight?
Let us know.
Send us an email,
send us your thoughts podcast,
we productions.com.
All right,
well,
uh,
today is Friday.
We've got,
oh KSI on Tuesday.
It'll be exciting.
We'll go to lots of tall.
No we didn't.
So case size on Tuesday.
That's our episode next week.
I'm working on the h three video.
Hopefully will be out this weekend.
I don't know.
Who knows?
We'll see.
I'll do my best with that all being
said.
How'd we do today?
We did solid.
However the numbers chuckles back here.
I think the numbers are low because I
heard people say it wasn't showing up.
Yeah.
I apologize to anybody that didn't get
the notification.
I mean eyes that I got it on my phone.
Um,
but yeah,
I guess in the tweet I saw some
responses that people were having
trouble finding the episode today.
So we will,
we will investigate,
maybe emailed the,
our context that,
um,
even when I went to our podcast channel,
you know,
we'll usually show there and doing the
show.
I have to click on the video.
Lee,
what the hell you to,
enough people found that cause we're at
like 17,000
now.
Ultimately it did well.
But,
um,
but yeah,
anybody that,
uh,
I got screwed by that and we apologize
to find that strange.
I wonder if there's a thing in the
settings we fucked up or not likely just
say youtube bug.
I think it's gotta be,
cause again,
I did get it.
I mean I got all the notes.
Look and we have a contact.
We can email it.
Youtube,
right?
Yeah.
We'll,
we'll reach out.
We'll figure out what happened.
Oh Man.
You gotta Love Youtube.
It's like never know what you're going
to get.
Imagine being like NBC and you're like
new episode of Seinfeld.
Maybe half of the People's TV's don't
turn on half a half of everybody just
gets scrambled waves when they turn on
NBC imagined.
All right guys.
Have a great weekend.
The morals of bad science Tuesday and
that'd be it for this week.
Hey guys.
All right.
Is this,
it is Friday,
right?
It's Friday.
Well,
what do we have to do was so mixed up
lately.
I don't know the week.
Friday.
Tomorrow we've got dinner.
Yeah.
Sound Dave.
We've got dinner.
Dad's birthday.
Oh yeah.
My Dad's birthday.
We're going to take him out Monday.
We've got shit to do.
I hate having stuff to do on the
weekend,
you know?
So it's
okay.
You feel free to edit anything.
All right,
bye everybody.
We're going to know,
okay.